[Music]
what are you enjoying about this journey
with three right now everything about it
i'm loving it taking care of a girl
absolutely holding that umbrella for you
remember that corny joke of mine from
them yo asap
did you let me stand under your umbrella
tonight
[Laughter]
you gotta stop with that that's an
ongoing joke you guys retire that one
we're so happy for it but what are you
looking forward to as you move into a
new chapter of your life
i'm just excited for what i don't know
yet you know
everything is new to me so
you know i'm excited
how are you keeping track of the
milestones as the two of you go through
this journey together
i mean i'm just living
i'm living we're just living life i want
you two to collaborate on some new music
maybe even some lullabies i told ree i
said girl drop us a lullaby or something
maybe not
thank you though and tonight we are
celebrating fenty of course what is it
about fenty beauty and fenty's skin that
you feel like is just really
knocking it out of the park right now
because it resonates with so many people
look at it speaks for itself exactly
[Music]
you